i have very interesting
um scenario slash analogy
okay for you okay
and it's gonna prove this will prove
once and for all
okay depending on your answer okay we'll
prove or disprove once and for all
that men are just as if not crazier than
women right
okay and i always say that's crazy and
they are but
men can be just as bad and this is
exactly how okay
so scenario right so you're chilling at
home
you're just you're vibing you're just
watching like vikings or something
you're getting into it you're like
on a three ep binge of vikings in your
deep
yeah all of a sudden
one yap bangs on your door okay bangs
and you're thinking what the [ __ ] is
that you open the door it's just some
random woman
she's slightly piff but she looks
frazzled mm-hmm runs in she's slightly
she runs in and she's like ah i'm really
really sorry
i'm just like i'm i'm panicked um i'm
trying to get away from like someone
who's stalking me right
okay and you're like [ __ ] okay cool and
you're like can i just crash here for a
little bit
okay like not sleep or anything but can
i just stay here for like five ten
minutes okay until it dies down and i'll
leave and obviously you're confused and
you're like okay whatever
so she sits down with you watches
vikings and she's acting weird fam
acting weird okay and she's like what's
this and you're like oh vikings i'm just
watching vikings she's like vikings of
[ __ ] turn off
and she's just her actually is all over
the place she's moving scotty she's
moving scatty okay and you're looking at
her and you're thinking
okay maybe i [ __ ] up yeah the more she
talks the more you think
ah i shouldn't know she's like there's
no one
yeah there's no one following her yeah
she just wants to come she just wanted
to crash in some random person's house
yeah so you're like all right cool
um and then you give it your respectable
10 minutes you know alright cool it's
been ten minutes um
i think like you should go kind of thing
and she's like now give me another 10.
give me another 10. she's acting weird
she looks like she's acting like she's
been on crack but she's clean and she's
like stable and stuff like that but
she's just acting
[ __ ] nuts okay so you're like okay
i'm getting concerned
she's like give me another thing give me
a little smile like you're not doing
nothing she's that aggressive in that
and you're like
no no no no i'm sorry but get your [ __ ]
and get out like this is my house i
don't even know you like get out
and she said now and you're like nah you
need to leave and she's
she's that she squares up she's a big
man make me
make me and you're like
nah this is this is crazy now now you're
thinking
i'm muddled up with something nuts yeah
i've muddled up with something crazy
yeah yeah yeah so you're like nah
seriously get the [ __ ] out
she said nah come on big man make me fam
she puts hands on you
yeah pushes you smacks you up
paws on you cuz and she says get me out
of this house then
and she starts cussing you out calling
you a [ __ ] prick
x y and z yada yada
so then the best thing you can do
because you're so [ __ ] vex now she's
dashed a drink in your face everything
she's trashing up the yard
now you're angry here yeah you see what
you're doing now yeah you're feeling at
times ten yeah you're vexed
and you're thinking but you know there's
that's drinking my face that's drinking
your face you're thinking now this [ __ ]
has taken absolute piss obviously she's
a woman you can't hit her back yeah
so you think [ __ ] it you pick her up
yeah
you lay her on the floor yeah and like
you're a strainer yeah
that's the first thing i thought you
think you're a strainer and then you're
thinking i'm [ __ ] angry and she's
calling you
every name under the sun and you think
you're not [ __ ] this you go to spit in
her face because that's all you can do
you go to spit in her face you think
[ __ ] this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] like she's wrecked my
yard she's out here calling me names
she's put hands on me
i've got nothing else to do i'm gonna
spit in this [ __ ] bitch's face okay
you go to spit in her face
yeah she catches it in her mouth
licks her lips stares at you
and says [ __ ] me hard immediately hard
immediately
i lie hard immediately immediately
i was not petrified before i was vexed
and confused before
as soon as she's done that i forgot
about the first five minutes the 20
minutes that have happened
haven't happened i'm hard immediately
i'm concerned but i'm hard immediately i
can't control that
bro i can't control that men are crazier
than women
i can't control 100 hard immediately